two sisters one mind thank you okay here
we go
we love our favorite Disney Princesses
even if they have slightly less than
practical style but some artists have
imagined them as trendy teens with
modern day makeovers that looked
downright trendy whoa anna has strength
bravery and smarts now all she needs is
some pockets and she'll be really
unstoppable Rapunzel in the movie
Tangled
our beloved Rapunzel is trapped high
atop a tower by the evil Mother Gothel
she rebels by escaping with handsome
rogue Flynn Rider
but this pic showed us what it would be
like if she simply adopted a more
rebellious style she traded in a long
gown for long tattoo sleeves and we can
just imagine how much diet took to get
that pink tint if you think our gout
needs a new haircut check out this
awesome art from Instagram user pastel
ette she doesn't have to choose between
impossibly long or super short there are
tons of cute and stylish options in
between artist Nastya cosa nova imagined
Rapunzel getting far far away from the
tower and looking tan and sleek on a fun
Beach vacation or she could treat
herself to a post confinement shopping
spree while looking stylish and comfy
Ariel founder yeah apparently artist
Nastya Costa Nova thinks Ariel would
want to shut her fins and slip into a
pair of ultra high heels she might need
a little practice but what better way to
celebrate her new feet or maybe Ariel
could be part of our world while
maintaining a sense of her mermaid
aesthetics like in this picture by the
tillich o high-waisted jeans with a
peekaboo top could even need King
Triton's high standards artist Anusha
Saeed created this cute pic of Ariel
looking Beach ready in some casual
shorts and a t-shirt and don't think we
missed that adorable dinglehopper
keeping her bangs in place Moana slowed
Ana's disney style is great for riding
the waves but Ryu key car you give us a
look at a more relaxed style for this
voyager wearing a flowing maxi dress is
a great way to look chic on the beach
Moana knows you don't need to be shiny
to look amazing
instagram user pastel edge showed us
some ways Moana could switch up her
hairstyle while still embracing her
gorgeous natural texture after all
wouldn't facing down monsters and
traversing the ocean be easier with your
hair pulled back finally Nastya
kosanovich shows us what Moana could
look like if she heads inland it's
totally different from her usually
beachy look but we're totally here for
it Elsa that is not what magic does it's
just your fear fear is what can't be
trusted tumblr user pansy ella
showed us what Elsa could look like if
she gets to enjoy some warmer weather we
love her new pink color palette and the
fact that she isn't restricted by a
floor-length gown real-life identical
twins Danielle and Nicole Harry gave
Elsa and her sister Anna updated looks
and gave both siblings pants and pockets
what's more magical and practical than
that we love that these princesses look
so trendy with their vintage inspired
looks
anna elsa and anna are siblings but
Nastya Casanova explored what they would
look like with the different styles
Elsa looks sleek while anna is comfy and
casual in an oversized jean jacket
tumblr user pansy Allah created this
outfit which shows us that even royalty
can look great with their hair pulled
back into a bun meridah meridah
definitely strikes us as the kind of
princess who favors comfort over fashion
so we love that artist Nastya cosa Nova
gives us both this brave look features
an oversized t-shirt and short books
which has this princess dressing like
athleisure queen kylie jenner
deviant-art user ff69 showed us a Merida
that looks pretty sporty and gorgeous
and a practical pair of slacks with some
stylish slashes buttercup LF shows us
another trendy teen Merida complete with
boots leggings and her iconic red hair
whether she's on the big screen or
strolling through the mall
we're glad Merida is embracing her
natural law
jasmine
Princess Jasmine got a live-action
update in the new Aladdin movie but
let's see her in some more everyday
styles artist Dave Salamanca created
this gorgeous modern Jasmine with a
stylish year top and a Gucci belt fit
for a princess a new shot gave us a
conservative version of jasmine with her
hair tucked back in a scarf and some
top-notch accessories although we aren't
sure we want to know where that tiger
print bag came from there's no denying
this jasmine looks great
Tiana my mama always said the quickest
way to a man's heart is through his
stomach Buttercup LF also gave us an
adorable version of Tiana from The
Princess and the Frog that looks like
she's ready for a day at a Disney part
it may take a little bit of fairy dust
to get those thigh-high socks to stay up
but it's worth it running a restaurant
is hard work and tiana looks cute on her
caffeine run in this pic from tumblr
user Alan Torrie deviant art user by RIA
13 created this modern version of tiana
wearing a short dress and cute ankle
boots it might not be the ideal outfit
for working in a kitchen but it's a
perfect nice yet casual look for date
night which hopefully won't end up in
kissing a frog mulan Nastya Casanova
took a high-fashion approach to Milan
who defeated the Huns and has now moved
on to conquering the mall saw Mulan is
an incredible hero who saved all of
China so the least we can do is show her
off in an awesome outfit artist Fernando
suárez created this version of the
character who probably paid a lot for
the perfect haircut instead of sharing
it off with a sword the unique cut of
her shirt and shining accessories really
put her look together making her look
tough but still stunning fell strolling
around town in a dress is fine but this
out been imagined by artist Dave
Salamanca is so much trendier we love
the ankle boots and smart coat combined
with Belle's signature hairstyle
checking in with her dad after being
kidnapped would have been a lot easier
if Belle had a cell phone like we see in
this redesigned by deviantART user and
we love that Bell has paired a fun
textured skirt with a satin jacket
complete with a rose apocalypse eeeh art
showed us what it would look like if
Belle opted for a less formal ball gown
for her first dance with the Beast
Cinderella oh well yes my gressil just
have to wait Cinderella is a classic
Disney princess who was forced to do
more than her fair share of chores and
we're impractical glass heels to a dance
but artist Fernando suárez gave this
princess a much more modern look
including a pair of high-waisted jeans
Nastya casino VII imagine Cinderella on
a royal shopping spree looking stunning
in a long blue jumpsuit with a pair of
high heels that thankfully aren't made
of glass snow white snow white may have
learned to be wary around her favorite
fruits but she's still willing to take
fashion risk artist Fernando suárez
created this beautiful image of our
princess showing off her shoulders
instead of hiding them behind poufy
fabric the ruffle on her shirt is a big
upgrade from her old dresses oversized
collar and makes her look much more
modern wants her evil stepmothers out of
the pictures snow is free to go shopping
in this bold and bright outfit by Nastya
Casanova this sleek monochrome look is
similar to one we saw the stylish
zendaya wearing Aurora artist Philip
light shows Aurora heading far away from
her spinning-wheel in a cute top and
shorts with some delicate sandals even
though her hair has a bit of that
impossible Disney curl she still looks
totally realistic Instagram user
Victoria Evans created this more formal
version of Aurora who looks like she
would fit right in at a proper private
school there's also this adorable image
by deviant art user pariah which shows a
wide-awake Aurora with bare shoulders
and a cute modern strapless dress this
dress is definitely for a night out and
not sitting at a spinning wheel
Esmerelda
we all know that this character tends to
stand out which is why we love Nastya
Costa Nova's depiction of her in this
over-the-top dress maybe it's a little
bit extra but you can't deny the fact
that she looks absolutely fabulous
okay so as Morelle de might be not an
official Disney princess but this
gorgeous green eyed character with a
heart of gold definitely deserves a
modern makeover deviantART user Kisuke
shows us how much the right cut can help
update an outdated style by shortening
esmeralda skirt and toning down her
sleeves she now looks like a trendy teen
Tinkerbell Tinkerbell from Peter Pan is
definitely a diva so she deserves to be
styled like one of our favorite celebs
Nastya Casanova showed us this picture
of the iconic fairy in an oversized
sweater with a pair of thigh high boots
is anyone else thinking about ariana
grande right now deviantART user Furno
figured out that flying around in a
short dress isn't always the most
practical tinkin sprinkle fairy dust
around just fine in a pair of sneakers
and shorts Pocahontas Pocahontas can
talk to trees sing with all the colors
of the wind
and look great in a crop table this
picture from deviantART user Nutt Teleco
shows us Pocahontas rocking some fringe
and a pair of short shorts while hanging
out with some of her animal friends our
end zze went in a different direction
showing Pocahontas taking a selfie while
pairing a beanie with a fringe dress we
love the feathers incorporated in her
hairstyle and on her tattoos meanwhile
Nastia cosas Nova went in a totally
different direction to give us a sleek
modern Pocahontas rocking a pencil skirt
an embellished jacket Jane Porter if you
want to see a Jane that's ready to
explore the jungle check out this
version by Isaiah Kay Stephens sure
she's dressed like Lara Croft
from the Tomb Raider series but a pair
of boots pants and a tank top are still
in style without sacrificing
practicality Tarzan's Jane Porter is a
caring woman who definitely seems smart
enough not to wear a formal gown in a
jungle so she definitely does
an upgrade to this sophisticated design
by deviantART user gotohelp we've seen
plenty of magic in Disney films but now
we can behold the power of a properly
fitted suit llegará well you know how
men are I think no means yes and get
lost means take me on yours
Makara from Disney's Hercules is an
incredibly underrated character and one
of the few who's properly skeptical
about romance are n Z Z Z imagines her
looking like a bit of a bad girl with an
off-the-shoulder shirt showing a hint of
what's underneath Nastya cosa Nova had
her embrace her bad girl minion of Hades
vibes in this lux looking leather outfit
it's a stark contrast to our usual
flowing gown which is why we love it so
much in fact it kind of looks like
something we could see the fabulous
Rihanna rocking but is makaras ancient
look really that outdated Alice and now
we're finally getting to Alice in
Wonderland or is she in the real world
since we spotted model Noelle Capri
berry wearing this familiar yet unique
looking pale blue dress
then there's spooky version of the
classic story by deviantART user Emily
chose Alice wearing a much more
practical outfit for exploring another
world and as all Billy Eilish fans know
wearing an oversized shirt and shorts
can still look stylish Princess Leia I
should expected to find you holding
Vader's leash I recognized your foul
stench when I was brought on board even
though she's been more recently known as
Leia Organa let's not forget that
Princess Leia is kind of a Disney
Princess deviantART user shirelle
incorporated her classic hairstyle into
a modern all-white ensemble with a top
notch Star Wars reference Alexia Bradley
reimagined Leia as a trendy teen
representing the Rebel Alliance and
looking pretty in pink tumblr user miss
muggle gave Leia a cute choker some
stylish ankle high boots and of course a
Star Wars shirt which Disney Princess do
you think needs a more modern makeover
do you think you could pull off any of
these styles share your thoughts with us
in the comments section below and don't
forget to click subscribe for more
videos from us here at the things we'll
see you next time
you